빌사남이 간다. 오늘은 명동에
왔습니다.
뒤에 보이는게 저 신세계 본점인데
저기 전강판 아마 많은 분들이 알고
계실 것 같아요. 그래서 뭐
크리스마스 때라든지 새해라든지 이럴
때 되게 화려한 어 그런 정강판을 좀
틀어 놓는데이 정강판이 아무래도 관광
명소이다 보니까 외국인들도 이쪽으로
좀 많이 오거든요. 명동에 좀 상징이
된 그런 정강판이지 않나 싶습니다.
그래서 여기뿐만 아니라 여기 일대를
좀 정강판을 많이 설치하려고 하는 거
같아요. 그리고 제가 저 혼자 안
왔어요. 그래서 일전에 한번 같이
촬영했던 정성문 이사님은 모셨습니다.
네. 안녕하십니까? 또 초하게 된
정성문 이사라고. 평소에 명동에
대해서 어떻게 생각하세요? 아, 전
명동은 사실 내국인이 오는 지역보다는
외국인이 오는 지역이라고 좀 생각이
들고 지금 내국인들 수요가 많이
떨어진 상태다 보니까 외국인들이 많이
찾는 이런 것들이 좀 더 투자의
방향이 맞지 않을 것 같아. 그래서
여기 사실 오피스가 되게 꽤
있거든요. 점심 시간 되면은 또
직장인들 식사하러 좀 많이 오고 있고
저도 연남동도 가보고 성동도 가보고
있지 약간 살아 있는 느낌이 좀 드는
거 같아요. 우리나라가 인기가 좀
많아져 가지고 좀 이렇게 관광객들이
진짜 많이 찾아오는 거 같더라고.
그래서 그때 코로나 때까지만 해도
공실률이 거의 50% 이상 됐다가 뭐
거의 한 자리 지금 제가 봐도 너무
좋은 상건 같습니다. 여기가. 네.
그래서 한번 저희가 직접 외국인
인터뷰를 좀 해 볼게요. 제가 한번
미약한 솜시지 한번 해 보겠습니다.
제가 영상이 담지 못했지만 일본
사람이랑 미국 커플 인터뷰했을 때
그분 여자분도 오신게 K뷰티 때문에
오셨다고 하긴 하더라고. 그니까
화장품은 무조건 살아올 수밖에 없고.
맞아요. 그리고 또 요즘에 올리브형이
너무 잘 돼요. 명동력 앞에
올리브형이 하루 매출이 거의 1억
넘거든. 예전에는 일본 사람, 중국
사람이 주였다면 지금 좀 휘업 쓰고
있고 중동분도 좀 많으신 거 같긴
하네요. 그죠? 뷰티라든지 이런 피부
미용 뭐 이런 그죠. 제일 관심이
있긴 하니까. 그리 예전에는 중국의
관광객들이 그냥 단체로 많이
왔잖아요. 근데 요즘에는 그냥 다
개배 요즘에도 그게 그게 좀
바뀌었다고 하긴 하더라고. 코로나
끝나고 나서 예전에는 명동 오면 누가
깃발 들고 이렇게 있었는데 이제 그게
좀 없어지고 개별 자유행으로 온다고
하더라고. 그래서 숙박업도 요즘에
그것 때문에 더 잘 된다고 하긴
하더라고. 그죠? 그래야 또 소비도
되게 다양하게 해가지고
저기 이쪽으로 가면 이제 그 공시지가
1위 지금 네이처 퍼블링 나오는데
지금 가림막 설치가 돼 있는데 저기
어떻게 우리나라에서 제일 가지고
공시지가 제일 높은 곳이긴 하니까
네이처블 한번
[음악]
지금 명동령 앞에 와 있는데 네 여기
올리브형이 진짜 장사야돼요. 월 1
매출 1억 나온다는데 여기고 저는 그
얘기 들었어요. 이게 소문 나면 어떤
그 중국 있는 커뮤니티 이런 곳에
올리 가면 뭐 뭘 살아 이렇게 해서
어떤 좌표 같은게 찍히면 그죠.
그죠. 필스. 예. 그렇게 돼서 한국
사람뿐만 아니라 외국 사람도 그렇게
해서 많이 찾아간다고 하더라고. 앞에
보이 이거 가림막 설치돼서 안 보이.
우리나라 공시가 항상 1등으로
나오는이 건물이니까.
어떻게 보면 명동이 우리나라 공시가는
제일 높은 거긴 하잖아요. 강남대로
내국인만 있다면 명동은 내국인 플러스
외국인이니까 투자으로 봤을 때 저는
명동에 투자하고 싶긴 한데.
외국인들이 찾는 건들이 사실은 지금은
더 중요한 지역으로 각강받고
있잖아요. 연남동도 좋긴 하지만
성수동이 지금 뜨고 있는 것도 뭐
팝업도 많긴 하지만 내국인 플러스
외국인이 진짜 많더라고. 근데 항상이
외국인 이슈가 중국에 한영도 있었고
뭐 코로나 있었고 예전에 사스도
있었고 그런 이슈가 좀 문제지. 그
이슈만 없다면 꾸준하게 뭐 K드라마,
K뷰티 아까 전에 만났던 사람은
이스포츠까지 이야기해서 한국 사람
외국인들은 진짜 꾸준하게는 막 들어올
것 같아요. 강남에서 일을 하고
있지만 명도 그냥 높게 사는게 여기
주체 상권에다가 내국인 플러스
외국인이 되니까 임대료에 공실에
달리스크가 가장 줄어들 수밖에 없지
않냐라는 생각이 좀 들긴 하네. 네.
그래서 여기 평당 임대를 보니까 한
작게나 50만 원 50만 원. 50만
원에서 뭐 한 7, 80만 원 가로
스킬 높았을 때 높았을 때 최고
높았을 때 그 정도 수준이니까 이제
여기이면 쪽은 도로 좀 좁은 데는
평당 한 2억에서 3억이 정도 되는
거 같고 넓은 길에는 뭐 한 3억
4억 뭐 이렇게 예이 정도의 매감이
되는 거 같은데 투자를 하더라도
인대료가 어느 정도 받쳐 주니까
투자의 가치가 이게 수익성이랑
어떻게피세차 두 가지를 동시에 노를
수 있을 거라고 좀 생각이 들긴
하네. 근데 이제 그런 리스크는 있는
거죠. 그때 우리 코로나 때처럼 땅이
너무 작고 예. 그리고 개발에 대한
제한이 있다 보니까 예. 특히나 상업
지역이 이렇게 되어 있음에도 불구하고
사실 개발 행위가 안 들어가다 보니까
조금은 밸류를 올리는데 있어서는
조금은 힘이 들 수 있다. 그게
단점인 거죠. 근데 또 그 덕분에
상권 자체가 좁아 가지고 상건이
퍼지지가 않고이 개발이 안 되 도로가
폭이 좁다 보니까 미국처럼 예.
그래서 하나씩 몰려 있어서 상관의
집중도는 좀 높플 수 있을 것
같습니다.
and 23 years old
years old we arean
we areing here
foreers the korean
korea why because of
the kpop wave and
everything but also
it looks really fun
like we don't really
have clubing culture
in
israel but here is
much more fun
It was my first time
days ago. Where meet
you? How was it? It
was fun. So, how
long you stay here
for Korea? One
month. One month.
Yeah. When you
staying in the host
or Airbnb or Hos
Hosel. What do you
do?
I just finished my
military service.
Service
right people going
to women
toore men. I know
you know thank you
for
interview really
appreciate than you
where are you guys
from? It the city.
My name is 정성 what
are your names?
So wondering why you
guys
theore so many
option China Korea
so many other
countries right we
were very curious
about the culture
the for me is the
first travel outside
Europe really for me
really I'm curious
why so many foreers
came to the
Koreause so many
people say K drama K
beuty so many
No drama beauty for
us is
not more for the
culture culture for
the eating what you
eat here very
good what you eat
here in Korea we
only have been in
seul till now but
really really very
nice. Where have you
been to
in the
name
to Yes.
Yes. We are here
days. Yes. How long
you guys stay? Two
weeks. 아 weeks. Two
weeks. Then we go in
전주. 아 전주. 오케이. 부산.
아, 부산. 인터뷰. 땡큐.
[음악]
전체적으로 촬영해 봤는데 어떠셨어요?
아, 명동이 생각보다 근데 처음에이
메인길은 괜찮은데 비면으로 가니까
공실이 좀 있어 가지고 명동이 저희가
생각하는 진짜 그때 피크에만큼
올라오지 못한 거 같아서 관심을 더
기울여 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
살라한게 그렇게 오래되진 않았잖아요.
네. 코로나 끝난지도 얼마 되지
않았고 메인에 저기 상전이 많은데
1층에도 공실이 있고 공실이 이제 몇
개 보이니까 예전 같았으면
바글바글하고 더 사람이 더 미어
넘쳤을 텐데 아직까지 시간이 좀 더
필요할 것 같긴 합니다. 이면으로
속속히 들어가 보니까 이면부터 방건이
이렇게 좋아지고 이제 메인으로
들어오고 이렇게 돼야 되는데 메인에도
지금 좀 비어 있는게 군대군데 보이고
예 이면에도 보이고 하니다 보니까
그래서 조금은네 강남으로 가야 될 것
같습니다. 그 강남 중에서도 좀 이제
오르만 그런 데를 명다지 찾으면 좋을
거 같고요. 그래서 영어 인터뷰 되게
잘하시던데요. 첫 번째는 놀라웠던게
이스라엘 그 전역하시고 성 이스라엘
여자분이신데 직업이 뭐냐고 물어봤는데
군대 끝나고 왔다고 하셔 가지고
이스라엘은 클럽이 없다고 해가지고
클럽 청가왔다고 하셨더 홍대 그래
그런 클럽의 문화도 우리나라 잘되어
있긴 하니까 이태원 홍대도 잘되어
있긴 하니 그런 것 때문에도 다른
저번 명동은 쓰 지나가는 거 같긴
합니다. 또 다음에 이렇게 외국인
인터뷰
할만한 것도 같이 참석해가지고 자주
출연하겠습니다. 언제든지 불러주시고.
여러분들 문동산 구독과 좋아요 많이
눌러 주시고 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하겠습니다.